[Music]
so you know we live in a very scary time
where our private information is
constantly being stolen and leaked to
the world so my way to get around that
problem is just leak it myself all my
secrets are coming out on this show
especially here in a segment we call PD
leaks ladies and gentlemen please
welcome my close friend and a roommate
of mine for years one of our resident
writers and actors Matt McCarthy
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
conceal it is sincere I love you very
much
man and I so the way we do this bit is I
don't know what Matt is about to say but
it is true yeah hot dog we've known each
other a long time right Pete long time
long time ladies and gentlemen
America I met this man Pete Holmes
2003-2004 somewhere around there so I've
been good friends with this guy for more
than a decade we've been hanging out
running around doing stand-up comedy
shows we were roommates like Pete
mentioned for several years two of those
years playing video games watching
movies beautiful late night
conversations and Pete and I booked our
first paying gig together oh yeah first
it was a commercial for Sears diehard
battery so that's fun a fine battery
right negative charge that's right
positive charge back in 2007 Pete and I
started making a lot of web videos which
were actually a part of the inspiration
for this very television show that
you're watching right now and I've
worked here on the show with Pete for
you know a year and change however long
and we've been through a lot and through
a lot together we've shared a lot yet
just the other day this very week in
fact Pete looked me in the face owner
and honestly asked Matt do you have any
siblings
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well Pete when you were at my wedding
two and a half years ago you saw my
sister read an EE Cummings poem that you
said was very moving and you watched my
brother you know the best man give a
speech that you said and I quote was the
most loving moving thing you'd ever
heard before
so yeah I've got siblings Pete and also
they're called brothers and sisters who
the says siblings what are you our
robot taking a census
please tell them I say what's up
[Applause]
[Music]